hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
at the beginning of book 11 of his City
of God Augustine of Hippo is providing
us with an interesting explanation for
why what he's calling a mediator is
needed at a mediator for what ultimately
for understanding the existence and
nature of God for Augustine that's also
going to involve understanding a lot of
other things besides just God as if that
was just a small thing the relationship
between God and the world a human
history all of these sorts of things are
going to fall within that scope and here
he's providing an account which doesn't
say well you can only learn about God
through Scripture alone he does hold out
the possibility of some sort of natural
human knowledge that is by using our
natural faculties of reason and
intellect to rise to the understanding
of God but he thinks that that's going
to be fairly rare so there is you could
say some scope for philosophy understood
in a classic sense as you know this love
of wisdom and in the modern sense as a
discipline that is disentangled itself
from other disciplines such as that of
theology to have a scope to have play in
these questions but it's also possible
for philosophy to be in some respect or
in some manners aided by what we would
typically associate with religion so
let's take a look at what he actually
says the fundamental question is how do
we know about the existence and the
nature that is what God is like of the
divine right and he says it's a great
and very rare thing for a person after
contemplating the whole creation
corporeal and incorporeal to
ass beyond those and to rise to
something higher than that now notice
that he says that this involves not just
looking at the visible or bodily
corporeal aspect of the created world or
even if you don't want to accept it as a
Korean world to say the universe right
simply studying physics or neuroscience
or biology or whatever it is that you
want to study alone would not get you to
this point you also have to study the
incorporeal and to you know because it's
incorporeal invisible world as well so
you would have to engage say in
introspective psychology which is
something that Augustine himself does
now through doing this through passing
beyond the created order one can reach
as he says the substance of God and when
you do that you do that through
contemplation through that is the use of
our faculties that we've been given
reason intellect however else you want
to understand it and now notice what he
says in this case this is not merely a
grasping on our part as the agent of a
passive object it becomes a relationship
it becomes a dialogue he talks about he
says learning from God himself that none
but he has made all that is not of the
divine essence and then he's got a
little bit of reflection here about how
God would speak to human beings and
that's worth looking at he says God
speaks to a person not by means of some
audible sounds didn't in their ears with
atmospheric vibrations or anything like
that he says not by these but by the
truth itself so in our intellectual
grasp of truth using our faculties that
are part of you know our endowment as
creatures it's part of a creator
order were able to engage with the truth
itself which is not a passive thing or
relation say between thought and and
reality but is the the reality itself
revealing itself in an active way to the
person so he says he speaks to that part
of the human being which is better than
all else in the human being and that
then which God himself alone is better
so he talks about this as well as how
were created in the divine image which
is something that you find in the book
of Genesis and then you know mentioned
at many other points in the canonical
scriptures that Augustine is going to be
talking about this notion of being
created in the divine image is not
unique to Judaism and Christianity
you'll find the Stoics also referencing
something like this a part of you know
ourselves
the highest part reason the rational
part is a part of God and alike to God
but this is some very important idea and
so Augustine says that's perfectly fine
that's open that's a possibility
philosophers or people who want to
engage in philosophy can in fact if
they're conducting their minds properly
attain to God without any sort of
scriptures and he sort of priesthood any
sort of rituals it's perfectly possible
however well that's true you might say
in the abstract for most people it's not
true or it's not possible rather in the
concrete why because we're damaged
screwed-up human beings and this
rational or intellectual part of
ourselves has been darkened it's been
miss shapen it's been led astray and he
attributes this in in large part to what
we can call the vices to all sorts of
things like pride or greed or law
and we could go on and on and on talking
about examples of that but it's not
really necessary his point here as he
says is this higher part the reason and
intelligence is disabled and it's
disabled from what not only from
enjoying the divine which is what you
would attain if you know you were having
a clearer sight according to Augustine
of the divine but from even fully
understanding it so for many people this
approach is at least for the moment
closed off although it's not closed off
for everybody and I've seen as offering
the possibility that some people and we
can call them philosophers if we like
we're able to do this so what can we do
in that case this is why he brings up
the notion of a mediator an intermediary
and notice how the mediation is taking
place it's not simply like a you know
game of telephone where you hear what
the one person has to say and then you
say the same thing down the line of
course the message gets garbled along
the way or anything like that instead
it's about a relation something that is
actually ontological something that
changes the fabric of the created order
as well as you know representing a new
way of understanding the divine so he
tells us that truth itself God or God's
Son and for Augustine is a Trinitarian
Christian these are of course going to
be the same in this man Jesus mediates
as he says between God and human beings
how does this happen
so he's got a very interesting and short
discussion of this he says he takes on
humanity without thereby losing his
divinity so he becomes as you know in
traditional Trinitarian theology he
becomes the god man
or if we want to avoid the sort of
gender exclusive there you say God human
he becomes Thais anthropos right he
becomes this bridge and Augustine has
this really nice sentence in here which
I have depicted by drawing this the sort
of arrow between human and God the human
being
is aiming at God as his or her end as
their goal and there's a lot of
different ways this could be parsed out
happiness knowledge wisdom all of those
sorts of things a renewal of themselves
moving away from vice to viciousness
however we want to frame it the human
being is aiming at God what allows there
to be this connection between the human
being and God is the God human which
uses the human as a means to reach the
end of God in this case the human in
question is Jesus Jesus is being used as
they means as a mediator as the thing in
between to attain that end and here you
know you might think about means and
ends brings to mind that does the end
justify the means well yes in this case
completely and justify in more than one
way but it is also the means
that's justifying the human being in a
different sense making them right making
them able to reach God the end that they
have in mind now Augustine goes on to
talk about revelation in different forms
so he says that this this mediator
reveals the truth about God first
through the prophets and then through
Jesus himself and what it is that he has
to say recorded you know in the things
that his followers write down but also
presumably and how they behaved and
interacted the things that they didn't
write down but remembered and put into
play and then through these apostles
people who are going or
and preaching the good news and
eventually through the Scriptures being
canonized being brought into a Canon or
a rule and a rule not just for this is
what counts as is you know
official stuff but a rule for practice a
rule for what it is that they would do
so for example there's a book that it is
in the Canon for you know everybody from
Catholics on eastward including the
Orthodox and the Oriental Orthodox
churches called you know Sioux rock and
that's a book of wisdom it's also called
the queasy asticus meaning the church
book because it was used as a rule for
practice very much you know set of
philosophical discussions in their
practical philosophy and that would
allow the human being to understand God
right so the last thing that he talks
about is the need for some sort of
testimony for some sort of informing
process or witnessing and he says the
things that were being given in order to
help us reach God are the things that we
need to know but can't figure out on our
own and you might say well you know when
I read scripture there's a lot of things
in there that are pretty common-sense
well might not be that you need to know
that thing could be that somebody else
needs that as a reminder right it's not
necessarily all tailored exactly at one
individual but it's it's supposed to be
you know providing a basis that could be
used for understanding that so Augustine
will go on and he'll make a sort of a
fortiori argument that is an argument
saying hey if you're gonna say that this
is you know valid in this respect then
it's even more valid in this respect he
talks about things in the world things
that are visible things that are
corporeal things that we can touch and
smell and taste and hear and he says
there's a lot of them we can learn from
our own experience right I mean
if I'm wearing clothes or not I don't
need to ask somebody else unless I'm you
know blinder in some sort of really
strange condition I can look down yep
dressed today not in that dream where I
don't have any pants or anything like
that right but there's a lot of things
where we routinely rely on the testimony
of others why because it's natural we
can't see the whole world we allow them
to tell us things and you know sometimes
they lie to us or but they're
misinformed or you know we don't fully
trust them but in many cases we do and
we couldn't actually get by in the world
if we didn't so he says a little bit
later accordingly as in the case of
visible objects which we've not seen we
trust those who have so in the case of
things which are perceived by the mind
and spirit which are remote from our own
interior sense it behooves us to trust
those who have seen them set in that
incorporeal light or abiding ly
contemplate them now what is the
implication of that how does that affect
all these other points that we've been
talking about so there's really you know
two ways to get at the truth about God
one is through our own contemplation of
God and if we can do that great we might
also rely on other people who are able
to do that sort of thing and perhaps
they can give us some useful guidance or
information about that or we might go to
the mediator who is there specifically
for that role and provides some way of
making it past our own screwed-up
intellect so that we can properly
understand these matters that have to do
with the incorporeal but incredibly
important at least in this perspective
divine so for Augustine this is the
account of why and how we need and rely
upon or use a mediator to get to God
you